il y à un phénomène de deux roues qui
apparaît surtout pendant la période
d'adolescence et pendant la période en
france d'abord et d'adolescence après
bien sûr on s'habitue ou comme différé
on dit qu'on est pas mal foutu on finit
par accepter la à partir de accepte soi
même entendre ou une autre personne s'en
aperçoive - mais là je le dis pour les
téléspectateurs qui n'auraient pas la
couleur
évidemment c'est faux ch quel bureau est
hors ue
comme son nom ne dit pas et et moins
auront donc alors quel est celui qui a
vécu le plus mal dans sa jeunesse d'être
roux je crois que c'est du sien voyez
pourquoi parce que je j'appartiens à une
génération où le conformisme était de
rigueur où il y avait un type physique
admis et puis tout ce qui était en
dehors de ce type physique été rejetée
on porter des costumes croisés
on portait les cheveux plaqués en
arrière on était chacun ou brun et moi
j'étais frisés et roux je pense que
j'avais pas de costume croisé pour des
tas de raisons
qui n'interviennent pas dans le débat
est ce qui fait que j'ai été mise à
l'écart xavier est arrivé plus tard il
est arrivé après soixante huitard façon
adolescent s'est passé après 68 et 68 ça
a été l'admission de la différence on a
commencé à considérer que chacun
cultivant sa propre originalité devenait
admirable puis il y avait eu cohn bendit
donc donc les roues sont heureux depuis
mai 68 un peu plus lui pas tous et ce
n'est pas facile pour tous les roues je
peux vous donner des exemples de livres
sortis récemment qui montre que
l'inconscient collectif à des pesanteurs
qui est indécrottable par exemple dans
le livre de max gallo qui est sorti
récemment et max gallo et un est un bon
écrivain page 22 il y a une phrase que
je cite j'espère mais parfaitement ses
il sent mauvais comme tous les roues etc
fougères c'est une phrase qui ne se
discute pas c'est sorti comme ça tout
naturellement nous donner un autre
exemple dans le livre de jacques à
bouchard dans les cages de l'ours paru
chez belfond je crois dans ce livre
jacques bouchard parle à la page 43 d'un
tortionnaire qui était roué
immédiatement il s'est dit c'est lui qui
s'occupe à la torture voyez c'est
formidable s'est pas trompé et il ne
s'est pas trompé en plus
non non il a alors le bon vous
conseillez qu'il ya une sorte de racisme
contre le contre les roues et qu on les
roule aussi des repas à dire que il ya
une persécution des rouquins au cours de
l'histoire qui n'a pas cessé hier que
les exemples que je vous donne prouve
qu'il ya encore une espèce de
ségrégation lire ou parle le
le vocabulaire quand on dit rookie bij
convient autant dit poil de carotte
on reçoit beaucoup de lettres depuis que
le livre est sorti dix ans mais vous
êtes un peu en deçà de la vérité
oui alors le livre de sonia rykiel par
exemple sonia rykiel dents et je la
voudrait lui qui est sorti chez grasset
et quelques temps dans ce livre elle
parle de son enfance et sa mère lui
frotter la tête en disant mais pourquoi
es-tu tâche et pourquoi est il caché qui
n'est pas comme les autres qui est
différent pourquoi est elle ne comprend
pas sa différence alors c'est vrai que
les roues ont été souvent en egypte ont
été persécutés on a brûlé les roues oui
maintenant donner aux blés la couleur
des roues oui lorca et moelleux en
lisant votre livre
j'ai fait plusieurs colonnes les mots
verrous et les génies rouler rouler les
roues superbe et c'est quand même les
mots verrou vous dites 20 étaient
persécutés les barberousse eric lerouge
henry vite néron et gilles de rais 1
c'est pas des gens l'abri cela arrive
souvent quand on nous attaque on se
défend ah oui là c'est un peu facile là
quand même donc les roues sont pas non
plus des noms c'est vrai vous avez vu la
préface de skyrim d'envoyer ce qu'on a
mis en exergue de julien green dit
enfin il si la personnage je suis roues
le roux est un homme à part aux mêmes
maux mais sans tarder et dire que pour
un bon goût au jeu peux vous citer
automatiquement un mot vers où le christ
et judas j'exclus judas était on ne sait
pas que je désire ronde mais
l'inconscient collectif le donne roue
celle essentielle bio vous ne tombez
bien après vous à l'école j'avais droit
à un petit refrain que paul gilbert qui
est oria liste du quotidien de paris a
entendu aussi que nicole courtois il a
entendu aussi c'était la rouquine a fait
des petits derrière la commode le
rouquin les a trouvés les a bouffés ça
ça m'a suivi pendant plusieurs années
si vous vous sentiriez pas persécutés
avec un refrain de 6 non non non mais si
bien sûr à l'école c'est évidemment la
vie c'est là surtout que c'est terrible
pour les pauvres l'adolescence aussi
adolescents mais après quand on est
adulte
on oublie trop sa soeur de tête je m'en
parlait au touquet il ya quelques temps
et dans la voix du nord j'ai lu un
article sur les chasseurs de têtes et on
a dit que les chasseurs de tête et
éviter d'engager des grands délits qui
est derron je peux vous citer le
d'ailleurs dupont compte at-il c'est
très difficile de trouver des roues
parce que vous racontez dans les
frustrations d'un ruisseau solitaire un
rookie essaye de fonder une association
le rouquin wii qui arrive pas en trouver
qui veulent pas lire ou ne veulent pas
participer à leur masse en mouvement un
sens pas de culture non mais il ya aussi
une fronde il ya aussi une phrase de
lanzmann qui dit qu'en juin ou 15 change
de trottoir parce que on a l'impression
que ce d'euros deux rouquins on forme un
cas exceptionnel vous aviez mois on a
l'impression que deux rouquins ces deux
poids deux mesures et les coupes on
n'est pas un couple c'est deux fois plus
ridicule que c'est d'histoire d'amour
donc je râle sélection à l'amour de tout
à l'heure les rouquins ne se regroupe
pas oui donc on peut pas faire une
société des spa société protectrice des
rouquins parce que il
il serait mal à l'aise tous ensemble
j'ai un souvenir fou on m'avait demandé
de faire une photo publicitaire pour des
stylos feutres bon et la personne qui a
conçu cette campagne a eu l'idée de
mettre des rouquins parce que c'était
l'automne la rentrée des classes pour
parfait et on m'a fait rentrer dans une
pièce si voulez je faisais le papa il
fallait me choisir une maman et puis
huit enfants et on m'a fait entrer dans
une pièce où il n'y avait que des roux
et ben je vous assure que ça donne un
choc
effrayant
[Musique]